foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar
overcoming the challenges of accuracy
and detection in molecular assays I am
Alexis Krauss of Labyrinth and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labrades and brought to you
by Thermo Fisher Scientific
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit thermofisher.com
now let's get started
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is Interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I now present today's speaker Dr Peter
Holden senior business development
manager molecular Diagnostics licensing
and Commercial Supply at Thermo Fisher
Scientific
feeder's current role is in supporting
customers who purchase thermofisher
scientific products for commercial use
with a particular focus in supporting
the use of molecular biology and Sample
preparation products for inclusion into
diagnostic kits
gives over 15 years of experience in
commercial sales and is responsible for
ION torrent sequencing capillary
electrophoresis real-time PCR and
molecular biology products
prior to joining thermal Fisher
Scientifics Peter led a research group
and molecular toxicology at AstraZeneca
after receiving his Doctorate in plant
biology from the use of the University
of Edinburgh
Dr Holden you may now begin your
presentation
well good morning good afternoon and uh
and thank you for the introduction
yes
in today's presentation I will cover
some of the challenges facing
researchers developing a molecular
diagnostic tests
and I'll review options that are
available available to overcome these
challenges including enzyme development
lastly I'll wrap up with the quality and
Manufacturing commitment from some
official scientific and how we can
partner with you in the development of a
diagnostic assay
so what is the importance of a point of
care test
a point of care test allows rapid
detection of analytes near the patient
which will facilitate better disease
diagnosis monitoring and management
the disease can be diagnosed at a very
early stage enabling a quick medial
decision and treatment which leads to
improved outcome for patient health
based on Market Research reports amino
acids are cancel the largest market
share for Diagnostic testing
however by utilizing nucleic acid
amplification Technologies molecular
tests are highly sensitive and specific
with high throughput capability as
compared to amino acids
many of these molecular assays are
performed on portable platforms that can
be run in community clinics on most
remote areas of the world setting a new
bar for a true point of care diagnostic
assay
so what is the workflow for a molecular
test
it begins with the sample the DNA and
all the RNA
today real-time PCR
is at the heart of numerous diagnostic
assays with this potential for
quantification enabling assessment of
DNA copy number variation differential
RNA expression levels and pathogen load
whereas the original PCR protocols
assessed individual markers the trend
now is towards testing for multiple
Targets in a single assay
what we'd call a multiplex which not
only allows for high throughput testing
but also reduces cost and the time taken
to complete the assay
for our presentation we'll focused on
the amplification method used in
real-time PCR
so there are many challenges
become When comparing purified Target
material for qpcr
one such challenge is the time to
prepare material which makes it
susceptible to environmental and Sample
borne inhibitors
to detect the underlying molecular
changes in a diagnostic test a variety
of specimen types are needed which may
include cells from Buckle swabs saliva
blood Frozen or paraffin embedded tissue
stool samples and and many other types
however many of these samples have
inhibitory factors and the presence of
these factors such as Heming in blood
can result in the inhibition of the
amplification reaction resulting in
false negative results
other challenges include carryover of
enzyme Inhibitors from extraction
reagents and poor yield which is further
Complicated by low amounts of intact
Target DNA in the purified sample for
example
blood is a common sample time cancer
blood tests work by screening for cell
free DNA releasing released by dying
human cells
these tests known as liquid biopsies are
sharing promise but not only for the
detecting cancer DNA but also monitoring
treatment progress
tumor DNA makes only a fraction of the
total of cfdna thus to avoid false
negatives minute amounts need to be
detected and significant amounts of DNA
needs to be obtained to avoid biases and
artifacts
this is further hindered by Inhibitors
present in blood itself or coming from
blood stabilizers or purification
how do you develop a molecular assay the
choices you select the DNA RNA
extraction are interconnected to
amplification steps especially in the
enzyme choice
traditional enzymes such as Tac DNA
polymerase which are less tolerant of
Inhibitors will require a cleaner sample
therefore more investment into the DNA
RNA extraction step is needed
however if better amplification enzymes
are available that are tolerant of
Inhibitors then the requirement for
highly purified targets is less critical
not only do better amplification enzymes
need to be tolerant of Inhibitors but
they can also offer improvements in
other areas within your molecular assay
these are areas could be areas such as
accuracy
early detection with a faster turnaround
time
fewer steps or processes for ease of use
for the operator
a room temperature stable format for
ease of storage
at multiplexing as we've mentioned but
lastly
and probably the reliable and robustness
for a variety of sample types is
critical in developing your molecular
assay
in this section I will review the Key
properties of a preferred enzyme in
detail which will include the following
multiplexing to increase the number of
Target per reactions and conserve
pressure samples
processivity which is the greater
affinity for the template inhibitor
resistance and and working with
challenging samples
another area is thermostatability room
temperature stable variants as well as
thermal stability to alleviate
elements such as secondary structure
specificity and speed are also critical
speed as measured by the number of
nucleotides Incorporated per second
provides higher throughput and faster
time to diagnosis
Multiplex PCR technology allows
simultaneous detection of multiple
nucleic acid Targets in a single
reaction as compared to a single Plex
reaction
the gel data shown here is an example of
hot start Platinum 2 DNA polymerase in
multiplexing 15 Targets in a single PCR
reaction
the advantage of Multiplex PCR in a
diagnostic test is that it increases the
number of Targets in a single reaction
and reduces the sample requirement and
eventually and ultimately
conserves precious material
the next key attribute of a better end
enzyme is processivity which is the
ability of an enzyme to catalyze
consecutive reactions without releasing
its substrate as shown in this
illustration
highly processive enzymes incorporate a
higher number of nucleotides per binding
event and this results in much longer
at-cons
due to a high affinity for the template
these highly possessive enzymes are more
tolerant of Inhibitors as shown here in
this figure and in particular in figure
a
Inhibitors like hecarin or formalin have
a minimal effect on a highly progessive
enzyme such as superscript 4 reverse
transcriptase in the cdna synthesis step
as compared to enzymes with low
processivity
figure B
shows that a highly processive enzyme
can synthesize cdna from degraded RNA
more efficiently than standard enzymes
if RNA is used as a starting material
then high level of RNA secondary
structure can cause a problem for the
CDMA synthesis step
an attribute of a better enzyme is one
to form at higher temperature where
secondary structure is alleviated
as seen here by this by this figure in
this illustration
this illustration shows that RNA
templates are varying lengths were
reverse transcribed at different
temperatures
using a highly thermal stable engineered
mmlv reversed reverse transcriptase
the results indicate thermastability of
the enzyme with a hundred percent
activity even at 56.4 degrees Centigrade
specificity of an enzyme is another
property important to a diagnostic assay
because of the precise interaction of
the target template with the enzyme
one feature is to use a hot start DNA
polymerase enzyme which will only be
activated at a specific temperature
which is convenient if requiring room
temperature set up
in SGL data a PCR reaction was performed
after setup at room temperature using
Platinum to tack DNA polymerase
here we can see that there is no
non-specific amplification
even after 17 to 72 hours incubation
at room temperature
I'm Assad to see a PCR reactions were
prepared and incubated at room
temperature for 0 24 and 72 hours before
loading into a semicycler
highly specific
ation of a two kilobase fragment from
Human genomic DNA was observed even
after 72 hours after room temperature
set up demonstrating the power of hot
start DNA polymerators for large-scale
experiments
foreign
we have another gel which shows the
absence of non-specific of a
non-specific amplicon with hot start DNA
polymerase
in addition in figure B highly High
specificity can be enhanced with
thermostable enzymes as seen at higher
temperatures
these are PCR results from non-hot start
versus hot start DNA polymerases please
note the improved yields of the desired
amplicon and the lack of non-specific
amplification with a hot start DNA
polymerase
reverse transcription and an elevated
temperature enhances PCR specificity
mRNA for four different genes was
reverse transcribed at different
temperatures using oligodt or a gene
specific primers of varying
reverse transcription at 55 degrees
Centigrade generated higher specificity
of the desired Targets in the RT PCR
reaction
enzyme speed is important since it will
improve time to result in a molecular
test
the example shown here is a 15 second
PCR amplification as compared to a
typical application that might take 30
minutes or more
foreign
properties for your molecular assay
as you develop your assay
um and review these different attributes
you must understand there has to be a
trade-off
for example do you use a better enzyme
to overcome sub-optimal samples
against uh or versus a lensy sample
processing step to obtain your purified
Target so that has to be taken into
consideration
thank you Peter and now that takes us to
our first poll question we'd love to
hear your input here
true or false
hot start DNA polymerase utilizes an
antibody or chemical modification so
that the polymerase becomes active only
at the height temperature of the
denaturation step
true or false
simply click on that answer
give you another moment to respond
okay we will continue with Peter
in the next section I will present
information on advances made in enzyme
development by surma Fisher Scientific
which will help you make better choices
in assay development
we use several approaches in developing
a better enzyme first start with the
protein design to obtain an enzyme with
a desired phenotype second
examine the butter formulation and
optimize for specific applications
and then lastly implement
single-use technology to manufacture
enzymes that contain
with contaminating DNA below the limit
of detection
so let's take a look at these approaches
in more detail
it's a classic approach to protein
design is to isolate from an actual
Source such as tack polymerase from
thermos aquaticus that lives in Hot
Springs and hydrothermal vents
however this method relies heavily on
luck to obtain the desired feature
the second approach is by rational
design
an example of this is the superscript 2
reverse transcriptase
which is a point mutation in a gene
encoding the Maloney
virus mmlv reverse transcriptase
method requires knowledge of the domain
or the amino acids of the enzyme
the last approach is protein Evolution
also referred to as directed Evolution
this method mimics the process of
natural selection to steer proteins
towards a desired feature
with no prior knowledge of protein
structure or function needed
so this seems quite desirable how how
does it actually work
the process starts with a gene encoding
for a wild type or unmodified enzyme of
Interest
random variation is introduced into the
genes where a process of mutagenesis
generating a library of millions of
genes
each encoding for a unique enzyme
variant
functional selection pressure using for
example higher temperatures
is then applied to the library where
only the genes that coded for the
highest performing enzymes actually
survive
this process of random mutation
selection is repeated until the desired
enzyme function evolves
directed Evolution enables us to
engineer Improvement to enzyme functions
such as processivity thermastability and
more tolerance to inhibitors
these evolved enzymes are different from
other engineered enzymes because they
have been optimized for specific
functions
to further the development of better
enzymes we can also utilize Gene Fusion
technology to insert a protein domain
with a desired feature into the novel
enzyme
one of the Therma fissure enzymes Fusion
DNA polymerase is an example of Gene
Fusion which brings together a
processivity enhancing domain with a
pyrococcus-like also known as pfu enzyme
so utilizing a combination of methods
therm official scientific has developed
several new generations of of enzymes
such as Platinum to attack
DNA polymerase and superscript 4 reverse
transcriptase that can help overcome
some of the challenges
you face in developing molecular
diagnostic assays
Platinum 2 tax hot start DNA polymerase
was designed by two Innovative
Technologies the polymerase was
engineered by protein Evolution for
higher speed and resistance to PCR
inhibitors
while an Innovative PCR buffer enabled
Universal annealing temperature
in the top panel the Platinum 2 tack
shows higher tolerance
to Common PCR Inhibitors as compared to
other commercially available DNA
polymerases
in the bottom panel the ability of
platinum to attack the faster DNA
synthesis or fast cycling can result
in an overall reduction in PCR time
these features are critical to any
diagnostic assay especially when working
with sub-optimal sample types and when
requiring a fast turnaround time in
detection
similar to Platinum 2 tag superscript 4
reverse transcriptase was also designed
by protein Evolution for Speed and
resistance to inhibitors
and an optimized buffer formulation
in the top panel
the graph demonstrates that superscript
4 RT resulted in the lowest CT value
when compared to other commercially
available RTS
in addition the reaction time for
superscript 4 is 10 minutes
compared to say 30 to 60 minutes for the
other
reverse transcriptasis
in the lower panel Inhibitors can
interfere with cdna synthesis such as
Amine
has very little effect on the
performance of superscript 4 reverse
transcriptase
the five covered protein designs an
optimized buffer formulation for the
development of better enzymes
in the next section
I would like to present the use of
single-use technology for enzyme
Manufacturing
how does manufacturing impact the
performance of better enzymes
from various Publications it is known
that commercially available Tech
polymerators contain various streams of
bacterial DNA
as you can see here this is quite a
detailed slide but you know gives a
strong illustration of the number of
species can be found within DNA
these enzymes are typically contaminated
with bacterial DNA and other
contaminants during Manufacturing
most of these enzymes are recombinant
protein expressed in E coli and
therefore therefore it's not surprising
that they'll contain some bacterial DNA
as seen in this graph
um
of of a qpcr assay using note and no
template control here in the bottom left
hand corner
an uncontrolled DNA contamination intact
polymerase used in a molecular assay can
compromise both sensitivity and
specificity of an assay
the thing
closed single-use system
as we call sus
where disposable single-use components
such as filters bags and columns are
connected by sterile single-use tubes
for everyday
for sorry for every stage of the
production
the closed systems ensure that an entire
process is never exposed to the
surrounding environment or the operator
the product from this manufacturing
Innovation is a dna-free
DNA polymerase
the top panel shows two graphs of two
PCR assays performed using the dna-free
Platinum Tech versus commercially
available DNA polymerases
and both the testers for the absence of
signal and a no template control
no amplification
was observed in dna-free Platinum tag
whereas presence of contaminating DNA
and other enzymes can lower analytical
sensitivity of a molecular assay
since the signal of the contaminating
DNA can interfere with detection of low
copy DNA targets
the tight quality control for dna-free
enzymes provides an increased confidence
in the sensitivity specificity and
reproducibility of your molecular assay
especially for low copy DNA Target
detection
a small point of care tests are being
developed
so is the demand for room temperature
storage and stability of assays
unfortunately the majority commercially
available
commercially available enzymes on the
market are incompatible due to the
presence of glycerol in the enzyme
buffer
our solution is a liar ready analog that
contains the cholesterol level below 0.5
percent and still retains the functions
and performance of enzymes containing
glycerol
so with considerable experience in
identifying and optimizing buffer
formulations and lyophilizing we offer a
large portfolio of lie ready enzymes
such as superscript 4 reverse
transcriptase
that can meet the highest standards of
performance required in your molecular
assay
you can see from the figure that this
enzyme performs the same in various
formats I.E in layer ready format
lyophilized reconstitute reconstituted
and also the standard glycerol formats
so this data is showing the effect of
buffer pH on Therma stability the
protein thermal shift assay was used to
screen for various for the effect of
various buffer concentrations on require
thermal stability
um data from the protein thermal shift
software shows uh the the boltzmann
um upper panel and derivative
lower panel melt profile of buffer a
um
pH 5.5
um got for B pH 6 c 7 and D 7.5
the the data was collected
at uh um one degree Centigrade intervals
from 25 degrees C through to 99 degrees
Centigrade on applied by a system step
one plus with time PCR machine
and analyzed with the protein thermal
shift software
and that brings us to our next pool
would you like to be contacted by Thermo
Fisher's business development manager to
get more assistance for your research
yes or no
simply click your answer
and again that question is would you
like to be contacted by our business
development manager to get more
assistance for your research yes or no
give you another moment to choose your
response
okay
to part three
these new generation of enzymes which
will be customized to meet your
individual specification are
manufactured in our Vilnius biosensis
biosciences center of excellence
foreign
has over 40 years of experience
our expertise in in enzyme development
and reagent manufacturing and the
facility employs state-of-the-art
equipment and is capable of small scale
to multi-liter volumes of reagent
production
the capacity and flexibility of our
production facility enables us to
respond quickly to any throughput
requirements
therm official scientific understands
the importance
of adhering to Idaho quality standards
When developing a supply reagents for
molecular assays
all production work is performed in
accordance with ISO Management Systems
which means we are committed to being a
reliable partner that has a deep
understanding of our partners and our
customers needs
foreign
has been recognized by
therm official being awarded the most
prestigious shingo prize which
recognizes organizations for operational
excellence
so this is my final slide
um
and I just want to encourage a thank you
for for listening to this webinar
um and also just to say you know if if
you you have an interest in developing a
molecular assay
um and you have an interest in the in
the products that uh that we can offer
and the attributes these products have
then we encourage you to to get in touch
um with us
um at Therma Fisher
um
a business development Partners um offer
a large amount of experience and a vast
technological depth that we can impart
on you and uh and we can draw in
expertise from various teams within the
company especially within our r d
function to help you develop your assays
and suggest Alternatives or
um or even suggest alterations in your
your current setup
and that brings us to our final
poll
do you have plans to develop nucleic
acid development assay
if so is it three to five months
six to 12 months or no you do not have
any plans
simply click your answer that fits on
your screen
again the question is do you have any
plans to develop nucleic acid
development assay
three to five months
six to 12 months or no plans
I'll give you a moment to respond
okay thank you for your participation
so again yeah just just please get in
touch if you're interested and and you
have interest in in the uh in the topics
that have been discussed uh during this
webinar
so
um I will now close but I would maybe
like to
call on you for any questions if you
have any questions you'd like like to
ask more than happy to answer them at
this particular point but uh thank you
for listening and I'll take some
questions now
Dr Holden for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
thank you for the informative webinar my
lab develops molecular diagnostics for
ntds such as malaria our objectives are
to produce mbxs that are sensitive and
specific as well as field friendly I
would like to know if samples are
available for my live already enzymes
I would like to determine if these
enzymes May Aid us in our goals
well thank you thank you for your
interest
um great question
um yeah we we offer a wide range of DNA
polymerases and reverse transcriptase in
uh layer ready format and we would be
glad to offer samples for uh for testing
um for sure we can send some to you
um but for more details of our live
ready enzymes offering um I would
suggest that you visit our website
thermofisher.com backslash liar ready
enzymes that's one word so that's
visiting thermofisher.com and the
backslash liar ready enzymes and leave
your contact information and on the
inquiry form and one of our business
development managers will contact you
and um and set you up
and it looks like we have time for one
more question Dr Holden in your
presentation you had mentioned one of
the enzyme properties as multiplexing I
am working on Multiplex multiplexing
Diagnostics assays and want to know if
thermal fissure has any recommendation
for DNA polymerases
well thank you for your question
um in fact we have Platinum to tack
hostile DNA polymerase that I would
recommend you checked out this enzyme is
one of our new generation of enzymes
combining both protein design and unique
buffer composition that I alluded to in
the presentation and that allows for a
universal annealing temperature
Platinum tack uh it's Platinum 2 tack
hotstar can be used simultaneously
simultaneous amplification of many
Targets in a single tube using multiple
pairs of primers
however I do recommend verifying the
performance of each primer pair in a
single Plex PCR before starting the
multi collector reaction and don't
forget that primary design parameter is
still critical for successful Multiplex
PCR
um
yeah again for more information about
this enzyme please visit our website or
I must add to that that our r d teams
are always ready to help in answering
specific questions such as these and
providing consultation relating to the
use of our enzymes thank you
thank you Dr Holden do you have any
final comments for our audience
uh no just thank you for listening
thank you again Dr Peter Holden for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank Roberts and
our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through July of 2019. lovers will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event
until next time goodbye